in Florida the Dunham family moves into
a home that seems ideal but they soon
find themselves under attack an unseen
enemy tries to drive them out forcing
them to fight a war against the world of
the Dead
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and we're back it's episode 44 a
haunting in Florida yes this is a good
one because uh this one happened near to
us right in Deltona and involved a guy I
know yeah so this one if you saw our
last episodes we did the one that was
about what was the other ones we did we
did a haunting of some summer wind and
then we did the one that was called the
dark side um so you know what we're
doing like I said we said we would
probably do this as we go to kind of you
know regularly doing a haunting episodes
that we liked and kind of talking about
them and talking a little bit about the
real stuff you know behind the case
haunting in Florida was a good one
and I happen to know a dumb witch yes
well I'll tell the story kinda has it as
it happened yeah I mean literally but it
was kind of an interesting interesting
situation meeting there done yes I tried
to get him on the show but he was good
yeah yeah so that was kind of like the
cool the cool thing about this one and
actually the kind of cool thing about it
was even when we first saw it on the
show was that it happened in Deltona
which actually I don't you know I don't
know if a lot of you noticed but I am a
Florida native and I was actually born
in Daytona Beach Florida and we now and
we now live in Orlando and Deltona is
right in between those two things so I
grew up about 20 miles from where this
took place and you've actually seen the
have the yeah yeah I'm not that he's not
going to say where it is I'm gonna say
where it is but I I know where it is and
I really buy it and looked at it I
didn't go in somebody else was in it now
but I know where it is yeah I didn't get
any weird feelings from a place but
let's do it let's go ahead and do the do
re intro and then we'll start talking
about the case yeah so we'll just do at
first you know we're going to do like we
usually do going to do our little health
keeping and give props to the project
Entertainment Network and Armand Rosa
million who runs it and you know we've
been doing pretty good on there getting
a lot of downloads and yeah shaking up a
lot of new listeners and show a show
when the podcast is growing
exponentially not so much on the YouTube
just a steady growth on YouTube yeah but
you know if you're on if you
the podcast please subscribe to the
YouTube so we know exactly how many you
guys are on if you need to contact us
you could always leave a comment right
there and you can also friend us on
Facebook yep it's a third 10 o'clock
podcast Facebook and also let's see what
else usually like I usually do can I
mention my newest book the unseen hands
selling well and it's selling well and
if you would like a copy obviously it's
available in print ebook and audiobook
the SP are asked for a copy yes knotty
centum one right yeah um I sent them a I
sent them a PDF and I'm also sending
them a print copy oh you can per their
archive so it's going to be awhile for
they get it ok good to see you guys go
over see shipping the SPR has been
around for a long time yeah over 100
years right yeah yeah that's Britain's
version of the Tala mascot
yeah that's true and also I think the
only other thing I wanted to mention was
that I think I mentioned that we
mentioned this last week of the week
before that we are going to be at spooky
Empire in Orlando big horror convention
it's the weekend before Halloween
October 27th 28th and 29th and we will
be there all three days we're on the
author track we're going to be on a
bunch of the panels will be there cell
and book so if you are in the Orlando
area at the end of October and want to
see us in person then you can do then
you can come over and talk to us and
have your picture taken and we'll sign
stuff for you and all that kind of date
stuff I'll probably give you something
to drink - yes yeah I also have booze we
might have to ask very nicely all right
so that's probably all we wanted to
mention it yeah kind of get into the
inator now like I said since this was a
haunting in Florida and it happened very
close to where I grew up
it's funny because when you say that
you're from Florida I think people that
have never been here like have a
particular kind of maybe an idealized
view of it I don't know if it's
idealized in a positive way or executive
way but I guess because of Disneyworld
and because it's a big vacation
destination and stuff like that I think
people have certain ideas about it yeah
foreigners ten ten to think this is a
too
the area yeah which Orlando parts of
Orlando are the tourist area the tourist
areas know what a lot of people don't
know - is that Disneyworld and all the
parks and stuff like that are not
actually in Orlando
no it's outside its kind of outside of
Orland downtown Orlando it's just like a
regular City pretty much and we know
somebody people that work in those
places and this is just regular jobs for
around here yeah because yeah there are
so many people opposed you like creative
people and creative fields and stuff
whatever I'm good friends actually was
Minnie Mouse yeah and underneath all
that costume you wouldn't know but yeah
she worked as many mouths for a long
time but yeah so we've known a lot of
people that have worked at the parks and
stuff like that so we know all the dark
stories about them yeah but also what a
lot of people don't have to go yes
that's true and actually speaking of
Disney World
did you know and actually I didn't
really know this because I've never
heard these stories but the Pirates of
the Caribbean ride at Disney World
and the Haunted Mansion are supposed to
be like haunted for real yeah both
haunted by ghosts of people that used to
work there like employees that got
killed on the job or were killed and
wanted to spend I like there was a not
notice that Disney Princesses are nuts
hahaha oh yeah let's let's not go into
that I know you're talking about the
ocean but um yeah but other than Disney
World
there's actually like a lot of really
cool like haunted kind of history around
in this area some of it has to do with
st. Augustine which again I don't know
if you guys know it's not terribly far
from here it's about 30 40 miles from
where I grew up in Daytona and it's
actually the oldest city in the United
States it was founded by the Spanish in
1565 1585 1585 and that's got all kind
of ghost like walking around the in the
cemeteries and then the fort there's a
big fort there north yes and there's
ghost tours and stuff like that even
where I grew up in Daytona the Boot Hill
saloon which is like a big biker Mecca
it supposedly has a poltergeist
infestation I could check that out yeah
you should it's actually it's right
across the street from a big really cool
cemetery that's in Daytona because
that's that's actually Boot Hill there
little slogan is order drink and have a
seat your
another boy in across the street the
main button hangout right out there
Cabbage Patch yes you're the Cabbage
Patch no it's not near that um actually
Boot Hill is in the older part of
Daytona like on Main Street or Cabbage
Patch is kind of outside of the city old
I know where it is I don't know where
they related yeah it's like a little bit
outside um yeah Boot Hill is like where
is over on the other side of the bridge
okay let's stay back on target good
we're via run what we're beer all right
oh I also wanted to mention Cassadaga
too which is like a spiritualist
community still they're supposed to be
haunted and also there's a thing called
The Devil's chair but if you sit in as
the devil will talk to you and I got one
of those you have a devil yeah alright
so the episode of a haunting that we're
talking about today actually air as part
of it was season 2 which aired in 2006
and it was called a haunting in Florida
which is interesting because it was a
very straightforward title a lot of
episodes of a haunting didn't really
have very straightforward titles they
all had something like echoes from the
grave or something like well still early
on if he was first season yeah yeah so
it actually just kind of had more of a
titles it I'm pretty sure the vertices
in his first season reckon s/s season
yeah
still early in the run and again I think
and I think it's another thing that I
liked about this one
that's similar to the one how we talked
about on the dark side haunting episode
is because it's pretty low-key like not
a lot of crazy [ __ ] happens as well it
did in the end but we'll get to Anam
right but it's not like I was demon
decision or not you know it wasn't this
big crazy thing okay so basically this
one before we start off and ready I've
met Edie Dom yeah and I believe that
Dunham story alright but I've just right
off the top
I don't believe everything other people
had to say about this but we'll get to
it to the point yeah I believed it was
credible well one thing that I that I
saw like I've never met him in person
you have one thing that came across on
the show when he was being interviewed
was he did come across as very
believable
yeah and he's just like that in person
yeah when you meet him in person he's
just like that he's actually kind of
like a big gregarious kind of guy yeah
look kind of larger than life type
character and he's a big dude yeah he's
not a little guy well he was a US Army
Rangers are the range
and I'm X infantry so we immediately hit
it hit it off well they're born infantry
Newsies Ranger yeah he's not just a
regular tab guy he was a bad boy he was
in the 75th infantry he was in the
Wraith Ranger Regiment yeah so you know
which is a long story veterans know what
I'm talking about and like I said they
said he does not seem like the type of
dude it was just make stuff up or would
imagine things a to this extent you know
everything so he did come across a good
car yeah yeah he did come across is very
credible right
so something happens there yeah yeah now
the episode aired in 2006 but it
actually occurred in 2001
now what ended up happening he was
married to a woman named best at the
time he had a son who was 12 at the time
they met from his previous marriage
and him and Beth also had a daughter
together named Emily who I believe was
she was still a toddler she was like 1
or 2 and they they were looking for a
new house because you know that they
were running out of room and they wanted
a bigger out so and had been working in
like construction or house renovation or
something like that and don't know
doesn't he's still in construction so
somebody that he had done some work for
in the past at Ojai I have a house in
Deltona that um guys left it yeah well
he's like you can rent the out right now
see I'm not real sure because they
weren't real clear on the show whether
the guy that told him about the house
owned the house right or whether he was
serving as a middleman for someone I
didn't get into that when I was talking
to him so I don't know either
yeah because they don't really make it
clear on the show from the show it
seemed like the guy who told him about
the house it was his house okay and he's
like I'll let you rent to own it because
I know you guys are looking over our
house okay so they get this house it's
in Deltona now I don't know where they
moved from I don't know if they were
from the area or anything like that
previous to that it's not included in
the store yeah it doesn't really matter
story okay now the first weird thing
happens and this this is kind of like
another thing where like I got a
haunting where it's nothing supernatural
has happened yet but [ __ ] like this
creeps me out
it was just like the one that we were
talking about with some was a with
summer wind or whatever it was or it
wasn't summer when it was
family it was the one family where they
come in and there was a family only
living in there and they really is down
there like that crew sue the [ __ ] out
right right this also creep me the [ __ ]
out he comes to the house with the wife
and the family to show her the house and
saying you know do you want to do this
and stuff like that they get in the
house all the furniture is still there
which isn't super weird but it doesn't
look like anyone has made any attempt to
move out there's like there's garbage
there's newspapers open unhappy point of
food there was a half-eaten plate of
food in the kitchen it looked like
somebody had just been living their life
and then just got up and left or
disappeared
yeah and thought it was strange when you
first saw that is stranger I mean I
would be really creeped out if I were in
the house that someone said oh yeah
here's the house you can have stuff like
that and then there's like a half-eaten
food plate your kitchen and there's like
spoiled food in the fridge or there was
old food in the fridge or something like
that that seemed really strange and he
from what I remember and thought it was
strange but he was rationalizing all
this is a real nuts and bolts kind of
guy and he's not in the supernatural
[ __ ] he just thought guy just up and ran
yeah basically and you know like he said
because the house was such a good deal
and because they were going to let him
rent to own and it was a nice house it
was in a nice neighborhood his wife said
on their ship she met his wife anymore
but she wasn't that was at the time it
you know she said that it was a nice
neighborhood and you know they had to
take it so he basically said oh well the
guy who said whose house it was said he
would pay us to box up the stuff or
clean up the house or whatever and we
could use whatever's here he doesn't
want it anymore
okay you know weird but he's like okay
well that it'll just have to do because
it's too good a deal and we can't let it
go so they move in everything seems fine
at first as it usually does was that
Thunder and I was summer oh my goodness
Florida I don't know if you guys heard
that but yeah it was really loud so the
first thing that happened was just
little [ __ ] the first thing is his
wife's best she's in the back it looked
like um in the reenactment it kind of
looked like a you know like a screen
porch like a lot of Florida houses have
she said she felt like someone was out
in the backyard watching her yeah and
this and you know she said there's a few
was really really strong what she's like
that man I feel like somebody's out
there like looking in the windows and
you know so she tells that about it and
of course he's just kind of like oh you
know it's no big deal but I'll put some
blinds up tomorrow right so you know in
case there really is somebody out there
they you know they can't see in that was
just the first thing now the weird thing
is that the second thing that happened
was actually kind of a big deal what is
happening this is only a couple nights
later and it says he's sleeping and he
wakes up because he smells smoke yeah
and he flips out cuz he thinks the house
is on fire so he wakes his wife of his
look at the baby and it's like you know
and I'm gonna go find his you know this
fire yeah so he starts running down the
hallway looking for where the fire is
now while he's walking down the hallway
he sees something out of the corner of
his eye and he backs up and he looks in
one of the bedrooms and there's a guy
sitting on the bed smoking a cigar yeah
and he said now he doesn't say this on
the show but he said this to you yeah I
talked to him about it for evented 10-15
minutes yeah that's ticker episode he
said it looked like as real as me and
you he said it just looked like a man
was sitting on the bed it's like and he
didn't seem like he didn't seem like he
just glanced at it or no he said he
looked right at it yeah he said that he
said that when he looked at that guy
sitting at the bed at the edge of the
bed that guy made eye contact with him
and he felt a recognition passed between
the two that not only would that was
that guy was he looking at that guy that
guy was looking at him hand knowing and
that guy knew you have only have one yet
on the recognition and so the guy who
looked ha stop that he looked hostile
yeah that's from what I remember that
they said said he's got a really bad
feeling about the guy
yeah which actually he didn't mention
that on the show now I got a real bad
feeling about the guy and he flipped out
an attack yeah he attacked but the guy
vanished yeah like in the in the
reenactment they kind of showed him like
looking at the guy shocked and the guy
looking back at him like with the cigar
and then like he kind of moved toward
the guy like who are you or something
like that
and then his wife comes up behind him
it's like where's the fire and he looks
at the wine he turns around to look at
her and when he goes there's somebody in
here and when he looked back to the bed
the guy was gone guy was gone and the
wife didn't believe him not at first I
thought that he was sleepwalking yeah
from I remember that's what that's what
Edie told me she said yes that she
thought he was sleepwalking but he said
that it was just real he told me it was
just like you know this was like veteran
to veteran [ __ ] and I mean I was I was
buying what he was saying he saw it yeah
and and that that guy who looked at him
which don't like I said really it's not
kind of a thing it doesn't seem like a
thing where he just saw somebody out of
the corner of his eye or it's like I saw
shadow or something like that he
apparently looked right at the stick
yeah and in the episode the guys Begley
blue-coloured I think yep he still it's
pretty solid though he does yeah II
didn't mention now he just said the guy
the guy just had kind of an ominous air
to him
you know so I guess that's how they how
they tried to express that in the
episode yeah I didn't say the guy was
cool yeah he just said the get a really
ominous prayer yeah he didn't actually
say the guy with ghostly at all he said
it looked like a real guy but he thought
it was a guy yeah he told me oh you know
what man I wish I had recorded that
phone call but information of who you
know I was just talking to a bit uh yeah
if I remember correctly he thought that
guy was wet he was all in like denim
jeans and like a flannel shirt and that
he was sopping wet if I remember
correctly oh I remember you telling yeah
yeah because they didn't put that on the
show no and he didn't say that I'm
really told me guy was my sopping wet
with like a bunch of stuff like I'll run
his pant legs like grass and stuff and
stuck to his pant leg I wonder if he
said that wait been outside I wonder who
read that life on the show interview and
they edited it out although you'd think
that they would leave that in because
that's not that's pretty spooky Ed's on
my friends list he's gonna be here in
this show if I've got that part wrong he
can grant and comment in the comments
yeah that was shown this show yeah yeah
I think I remember you telling me yeah I
remember correctly but I got all commas
wet yeah remember
records okay so yeah so he says I saw a
guy this is a guy in here his wife's
just like whatever I'm going back to bed
there's no fire so I hope that and you
woke me up for nothing pretty much she
and actually she seemed kind of pissy
about this so she was kinda like
whatever like a little while later that
gets pregnant again at this point after
Beth tells him that she's pregnant again
and they're kind of happy about it you
know but they don't have a ton of money
but they're you know she's kind of like
oh it's a good thing and it's a good
thing after that it seems like the
phenomena ramped up some hmm and Beth
even said that I think that um that she
thought it had ramped up when she found
out she was pregnant
now she um like I said they had a
toddler and so she was pregnant she was
getting tired all the time and stuff
like that so when the toddler would be
put down for a nap she was taken out
okay so one afternoon she's taking a nap
she wakes up and she sees an old woman
in a house dress standing at the end of
the bed yeah I'm not really sure like
from the reenactment it was hard to tell
I don't think she initially thought it
was a ghost I think she just thought it
was some crazy homeless lady or
something like that was an old lady she
just thought it was an old lady that was
in her house so she jumps out of bed she
picks up the phone she calls that at
work and says there's somebody in the
house or something in the house but when
she turns around the lady's gone right
so and gets home and she's like you know
I just saw this woman Andy and she
describes the woman to Ed yeah and Edie
says that Felix ounds just like my mom
yeah and his mama just passed away a few
years before that farmer Creveling yeah
she can't I believe and so Edie thinks
it's kind of cool he's like oh maybe my
mother's ghost is coming back to like
look over you you're gonna have a baby
and stuff like that and his wife is just
kind of like oh she scared the [ __ ] out
of me I don't like hahahaha which I you
know I don't blame her as like I wasn't
creepy you like ghostly Old Lace look at
him capable of sleeping she's like
that's not protective she's like she's
just creeping me out
and this I'm correctly though he wasn't
really so sure is that - it was he was
yeah he thought it sounded that in my
mom yeah yeah I remember correctly he
was still kind of like partially in
doubt about what exactly was going on
the house and a Nile I think still at
that point because the more I found out
about the case the more I talked about
him you find out that you know yeah edge
kind of has a hard time communicating
what it is he doesn't like to talk about
yeah much yeah but we'll get into that
and yeah they did do a little bit of
that on the show too because he seems
like he's a very matter-of-fact person
he was in the military he's but he
doesn't like he likes being yes able to
control the situation right paranormals
not his thing yes it is not it because
and I think he even said this explicitly
on the show and some of his interviews a
few times he's like you know I kid you
know it's like you can't do something
about this yeah you can't do anything
about you can't defend yourself against
something that's invisible you can yeah
hold up and I think it was making him
very angry and it was making him very
frustrated that all this stuff was
happening to his wife and kid and stuff
like that and he couldn't felt like he
could do anything when you're handing
arrogantly when you're in the infantry
and the Rangers are you elite infantry
all right one of the things they bring
out of you kind of like in you get in
your in your training for your
conditioning is to bring out aggression
when something goes wrong fight it yeah
well that doesn't work with ghosts yeah
yeah you can't grab a hold of it you
can't control it so that would make that
what makes you feel and I've been in the
situation it makes you feel very hip
attack yeah and guys like that alpha
type guys don't ever want to be impotent
yeah yeah they want to control it or fix
yeah you can't fix it yeah not this one
you could really your feed Omega games
your own can but foot optimal average
more of a man yeah and you can actually
see this in his interviews you could see
that he was very frustrated with the
whole situation so that you would be
yeah but particularly someone of that
personality yeah and it intensifies yeah
so basically okay so the wife after she
sees the ghost she's like she's not so
jazzed about being in the house anymore
especially when Ed isn't at home so she
starts taking the baby out for walks and
kind of trying to start to stay out of
the house as much as possible because
she's creeped out by being in there so
one day she's had the baby out for a
walk she comes into the house to get the
baby some more juice and she's given the
baby some juice and then she turns
around all the cabinets in the kitchen
are open son
she's kind of wigging out and then she
closes all of the cabinets like being
like oh man I don't need this [ __ ] right
now and then she hears the shower
running yeah and now she knows no one
else is supposed to be home but of
course you know she thinks oh maybe Edie
came home and is taking a shower and he
came home without me knowing but you
still tell she was kind of like freaked
out she's like oh man I don't want to
check this out but she goes down the
hall and sees she hears the shower
running the shower curtain is closed and
then she goes in the bathroom she's like
ed is that you the water goes off and
then she opens the curtain and there's
nobody there yeah so at this point she
runs she's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] she runs
back to the kitchen and all the cabinet
doors are open again right so then at
this point she just kind of throws the
juice the baby to like fusses again and
she's outfit run when ed gets home from
work that day he finds Bess and the baby
still outside she's like I'm not going
if she was sitting outside all afternoon
until he got back home at this point I
would probably if I was in this case at
this point I would probably suspect his
classic poltergeist yeah there is a
young kid in the mix that isn't the
right age
yeah but he doesn't live with that
doesn't live with him and he doesn't
seem to actually be the focus usually a
true poltergeist case that the kid is
the focus so that would that would lead
me to believe that this is some kind of
vote what people would call a haunting
yeah possibly an interactive haunting
but I don't know there hasn't really
been any hardcore interaction at this
point other than seeing an apparition
that looks at you and seems to recognize
you yeah you might do consider that
interaction yeah it seems like haunting
yeah because I should know too that the
old woman that best said she saw she
said that woman looked right at her yeah
- so it wasn't just like they were
seeing some ghostly figure like slitting
through the room or whatever they they
seemed like if they are ghosts they seem
like they're there they know that
they're there and they know that you're
there yeah I've never seen a haunting or
or benek
you know no no neither I hope you guys
to vent but not Avanti
yeah so I can't vouch for the validity
we can only go with what other people
say yeah see during hauntings yeah and
listening to add something happened
there something varies yeah yeah
probably haunting if there is such a
thing as haunting this may be a good
candidate at this point yeah okay
because of all this stuff happening and
most of it is happening the best at this
point because that is out of the house
so you know at this point they're
starting to fight a lot because he's
like well just maybe it's probably just
my mom and don't they haven't hurt you
so you know try to just ignore it or try
to but you know she is not really having
it she's like you don't have to deal
with it I'm here all day it's freaking
me out I don't like being in the house
but she doesn't really want to move
because they both really like the house
and it's you know they can't really
afford it and stuff like that you know
they kind of reach an impasse where
there's like we don't really know what
we're going to do about it now at this
point um as I said Edie had another son
named Matt who was 12 years old at the
time in 2001 and he just stays with them
on the weekend so this one weekend Matt
comes there he is like sleeping out what
looked like the back looked like the
back porch but I guess it was like a
sunroom or something like that so Matt
was sleeping on a couch out there he was
out there watching TV I'm not sure they
did interview Matt who was you know now
growing up obviously but um he didn't
say exactly what he saw in the
re-enactment
they showed him sitting there and him
being creeped out like he felt like
someone was looking in the window like
his mother like his stepmother had and
then he heard a voice saying his name
yeah and then they showed his face and
he was like kind of wigging out and he
kind of looked behind him and the same
guy that that II did seen sitting on the
bed kind of watched through the room
right and that kind of wigged now matt
said that he didn't tell at her Beth
what he had seen okay because Beth
apparently tried to get him to say
because Matt was freaked out and she was
like once you see what you see and he's
like on
you know but do you know what I mean and
then Beth was like you know because Edie
was like well I don't want to involve
him and I don't want him to know what's
going on in here
and Beth is like well maybe he shouldn't
stay here if this haunting [ __ ] is going
on because we don't know if it's
dangerous you know we don't put your put
the children in harm's way any more than
we have to and stuff so they had fights
about that right so so there's a tension
building up in them yeah those various
tensions building up in the house okay
so Matt was only there for the weekend
he saw this thing and he didn't tell
anybody at the time and he goes back
home now a few nights later they wake up
and they hear noises in the house and
Edie said that it sounded like someone
was dragging a body like either down the
halls or on the roof or something like
that and he starts looking around but of
course he can't find anything now as I
said before you know ed is this big dude
he's an Army Ranger and stuff like that
and he's frustrated that he can't do
anything about this and so he just
starts yelling at the goats just get out
of my house stop you know stop messing
with my pregnant wife and it's like why
don't you mess with me and all this
other kind of stuff and getting super
aggressive toward him and you know Beth
is just like you know please don't do
that you probably shouldn't make a mad
you know antagonizing her something like
I was into attack mode whenever the
thing appears yeah pretty much and you
know would win anything manifests I
think there's also walking on the
ceiling there's yeah that does come
along later but yeah so at this point
they're just like they were hearing all
those noises like somebody they can't
find anything so at this point he
decides that he doesn't know what to do
about this - he's going to call a
paranormal research group for some help
yeah so he does the inevitable Google
search yeah and comes up with a
paranormal group yeah it was local -
Deltona well the firm Daytona Beach
something it would be spent on a beach
yeah it's very close it's only 15 20
miles apart right okay so actually other
that was actually another time had he
done that nollie does it have
one of the television series over there
probably yeah probably yeah
but um actually have been even worse
than it turns out yeah okay I mean not
that it turned out that great anyway
they're not good no no okay no my point
of view
we're at the halfway point now so we're
going to take a break and then we will
come back and we'll talk about the
paranormal to email we'll talk about all
the stuff that happened yeah and a
paranormal teacher what's happened
doctor okay so we'll be back in just a
minute it was a time when we raced to
the TV Guide to see what was playing on
monster movie matinee at Saturday
afternoon and in some cities that
evening it was all about werewolves
vampires giant lizards and those great
Japanese monster movies relive it all
every week as Jim Adams and Mark Maddox
bring you monster attack monster attack
takes a look at those classic monster
movies that we all grew up loving join
us every week on monster attack
exclusively on the project entertainment
network subculture corsets in clothing
is our favorite store for unusual
clothing shoes and accessories they
offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices so
culture also offers the cool selection
of shoes and accessories steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
checkout subculture online at subculture
corsets comm set subculture corsets comm
make sure you use the discount code 13
o'clock for a 10% discount subculture
corsets comm or visit their store in
Jacksonville Florida just off i-95 the
net rope cash to you on the podcast the
rental or and heavy metal drama these
with a common connection
brought to you by hosts
jump lock max axe smoking hold Hades and
ours real mordecai featuring interviews
and all with the stars malin flora the
Negev costigan Mondays on project
Entertainment Network
[Music]
[Music]
you
okay I'm we're back now at this point ed
decides like he said this is too big for
him to handle I'm going to call somebody
that ostensibly knows what's going on so
he calls
well actually what he does he did he
doesn't call them directly he goes to
the paranormal they said of each
paranormal research group I think
they're called and he posts like a
message on their website yeah which
actually leads him in contact with
several teams and I think they're all
kind of have a different different take
on the case where I remember correctly
right well no one you're working
together as a team because they are
remember yeah disagreement and it's
certainly key aspects and I'll get into
later but no the only well one ended up
lit and it ended up happening later was
another psychic but actually I think
they were kind of in agreement on what
ended up in the big venture theory yeah
well whatever but so what ended up
happening he posts a message on this
website and he gets a he gets an email
from a woman named Debbie Smith who was
a paranormal investigator from Daytona
Beach and she says call me and we'll
talk about this and so he calls her up
after explaining you know what was going
on so Jesse says well I'm gonna get a
team out there and we'll see what we can
see so it only took a couple days she
gets her team together and they go out
there now it was said and I think maybe
a lot of people that don't know much
about quote-unquote paranormal
investigation or kind of think this like
if you have all this horrible like
haunting [ __ ] going on in your house
it's almost like they feel like oh well
if I call a paranormal research group
then it'll fix the problem like it'll
get rid of the haunting she spit your
nails Buster's
yes that's what I mean he would you know
jeer it's just like you know when you
call the any kind of repair person and
they come to your house they fix the
[ __ ] they leave you know and runs like
that so I think that's what he was
expecting yeah and they even they had
the real dusty Smith's on there and she
was talking and she kind of said that -
she's like well she kind of you know
they kind of felt like we were just
going to come out there and wave a magic
wand and everything was going to go away
and so she had to explain to them she's
like look we have to do a lot of
research we have drill investigation
before we figure out what's going on in
your house and how we can get rid of it
so while they're at wall the team are at
the house they're interviewing the
witnesses and Beth is telling them you
know I think it got worse
after I found out I was pregnant and
like you know as yelling at the goats
and there seems like it's been year
worse or something like that now while
they're interviewing them they suddenly
all here evidently banging on the walls
that you know obviously there's no
explanation for and then on their on
their instruments and it's the
temperature in the house like drops a
lot so and and then starts kind of
wildly fluctuating I think a lot of the
EMF readings were fluctuating wildly to
it like as they were walking around the
house and figuring stuff out now so they
thought that was kind of weird and they
documented and stuff like that now
they're walking around the house and Ed
is telling them where he saw the first
apparition of the guy with the cigar now
while they're in that area evidently
dusty is standing in the hallway where
Ed was standing when he saw the guy and
she says that she felt something pull
her head back by her hair like really
suddenly yeah so she says okay there's a
lot of you know activity in this hallway
trying to set up the EVP meters and
stuff like that I don't know like you
know the thing about the show of
haunting it differs from paranormal
witness and that paranormal witness if
there was actually any quote of real
evidence captured on the case like
photograph you know they'll show it or
they'll play it a haunting doesn't
really do that no that's the problem
what does so yeah so you never know you
know so you have dusty Smith on there
saying you know oh we captured EVPs or
not it the letter is where is it they
don't show it I mean it's not Lee might
be on their website I don't know I
didn't you know what I mean then how the
case wraps up and Wyatt Wyatt wraps up
kind of infuriates me because the team
is claiming to basically hit the jackpot
but they don't want cashed in on it
again I don't use the jackpot which
we're getting that bit yeah so evidently
so after all this happens they they you
know record in the hallway they take all
their data or something like that they
say okay well we're going to go through
all the data then what
in a few days or whatever so the
following day dusty goes to get pole
property records on the house because
she wants to find out you know who still
live there he's so NAT blah blah
now she discovers that the house has
been sold many times in the past few
years like people haven't lived there
for very long before selling it and it
always sells for way less than other
houses in the neighborhood you know
leading some to believe that maybe
there's something the matter with it or
other people have experienced hauntings
as well I've seen the actual house
though I didn't see anything unusual
with that no it was a very common kind
of how he had area in a time when houses
were kind of changing hands pretty
quickly I don't think that was unusual
but yeah but they did mention it on
there and you know they also brought up
it's not the house pictured of course it
so the actual house was a lot more
humble than that
and it didn't it's a decent neighborhood
it's just that it's an older
neighborhood
most of those houses look like they're
made that 60s yeah which is I can
imagine because I've been through
Deltona many times so I know what kind
of the neighborhood's probably similar
to a neighborhood I grew up in right but
um you know so also they kind of also
explore the sacred land to the Native
Americans angle because they always have
to do that
and um which you know it might be as we
had Seminole Indians we had we had
various tribes and whatnot stop blaming
those buttons I know it's poor news I'm
gonna get wedding for every single
housing in America are you guys ready
not really but um you know we know it's
not all your fault never could be those
dead Irish men or all those dead Germans
near the railroads could it no I know
yeah and all the dead Chinese underneath
the damn railroad tunnels yeah why is it
I don't know I never hear about like go
speaking Chinese examples don't don't
ever because don't ever become unrest
'add I can't so I guess they're just
like [ __ ] them out but I got the
haunting ethnic huh that word have sir
okay okay so evidently dusty listens to
the tapes that she recorded at the house
and she said she heard a bunch of EVPs
suggesting a bunch of different voices
like they were a bunch of different
spirits right now she said that she
couldn't understand what any of them
were saying she also did note from the
property records that at least two
people had
I'd either in mouth or while they were
living at the house one of these was a
younger man or you know middle-aged man
just like the guy with the dinner and
the other was an old woman now you
research this part right was there any
you know I mean like was this evidence
ever shown that people died I'm glad a
is claimed that's we just like lying
they look because of the death records
okay like I said I don't know if the
people actually died in the house or if
they just died or if they just died
while they happen to own the house or
what have you but anyway that was that
one's happened in this house that's what
I mean well that's it see that's another
thing but I was like oh somebody died in
the house like yeah something died
everywhere happy people die every day
their ever you know usually a guy in the
hospital yeah and those people that were
in that house when they died probably
didn't die in that house they went to
the hospital and died that's what I need
set aside what yeah yeah that's not even
around as long as us Jenni we've seen
lots of people die their natural causes
and accidents and things like that and
I'm really not that scary and it's not
that dramatic yeah not really go to the
hospital to get sick you know they're
not coming back few days later they're
gone yeah and the thing in house do not
become albanist well well in the thing
too is that honestly if if people were
and like I know the paranormal people
say that oh it's not always good the
ghosts of everybody doesn't come back
because otherwise we would just be asked
deep and ghosts all the time right but
even if the house is like somebody died
on the land underneath your house for
sure yeah I mean considering all the
people that have died in the history of
the earth right you know I'm sure all
kinds of people have died on the little
patch of land that your house is on
before the house was there my dad lives
in Mississippi yeah and he has he has
hunting rights on a certain piece of
land that and but that land is actually
owned by the masonite Corporation which
is a logging company Brian he was out
there putting up deer stands in those
little shooting houses with the carbon
cutouts and you would find old medicine
bottles from the 1800s we were digging
one and that's it really I meant to
control plate with then doing here I
mean it was a town here but what
because yeah there's a town here in the
1800s and it looks like around the
middle of nowhere
yeah this is Mississippi world as hell
and he's like every tree in Mississippi
has been planted at one time or another
you know and maybe it's descendants of
planted trees and pretty much every
square acre had something on it at one
time or another this land has been used
and reused many times over there's no
real virgin territory in most of the US
if you're living in that area somebody
else usually would live in that area
it's not like some point or at some
point of that and even now like like you
said even if there's nothing there now
it might have been like some big
bustling town center at some point in
the past
Italy is built on its massive graveyard
yeah Italy is just and you'd be alarmed
dead people you would be alarmed at how
not long it takes yeah for nature to
kind of reclaim just reclaims and all
the stuff that you know if you've ever
seen that show like life after people or
whatever it doesn't really take that
long so dusty Smith you know actually
does she's like okay well this is like
way more ghosts and stuff than I can
handle
so she contacts either a woman she knows
or a woman that she researches this
psychic who lives in Pennsylvania whose
name is Kelly Weaver
now Kelly Weaver's thing is that she can
apparently get impressions of hauntings
and things like that just from a
photograph of the house now the
photograph has to only have the house in
it it can't have any people in it or
cars or anything like that so she says
to dusty take some pictures of the house
with no people in it send them to me
I'll hold them and see what kind of
impressions I get don't tell me who
lives there don't tell me anything about
it
so dusty does that when okay so when the
pictures get to Kelly's house she
doesn't do a reading on him right away
but she says as soon as she opens the
embolism looks at the pictures she says
she gets a headache she said that
doesn't usually happen she's like so she
knew it was going to be bad and she kept
like putting the reading off because she
knew it was going to suck when she did
it so she doesn't do the reading right
away meanwhile a couple weeks later ed
comes home from work and Beth and the
baby are outside again and you know she
says I just can't take it anymore I
can't be in this house it's like you
know I don't know what we're gonna do we
have to move
other stuff she's like I don't you know
at this point she's you know she's
pregnant she's like I don't want to have
another baby in this house and it's just
like the whole atmosphere of it is
[ __ ] up and I just can't
so as like we can't afford it and and
then you know they're fighting and still
and just everything was just really
stressful and all this other kind of
crap and then Beth also said that she
noticed that their toddler daughter
Emily was really irritable like she
wasn't getting any sleep and so you know
they thought that was kind of strange
so then ed is like it's been a while and
Ed keeps calling dusty go and you know
what's going on it's like are you guys
can you guys get rid of this stuff or
whatever now apparently just like in The
Amityville Horror every time he's trying
to call dusty to get an update like the
phone keeps [ __ ] up like the keys in
the connection stuff it wasn't a cell
phone over the landline because it's
2001 you know so he's getting frustrated
Beth said he was getting to the point
where he was just getting not violent
but he was just everything would set him
off and he was just really crabby and
all this other stuff so finally he gets
hold of Dusty's as I can't take it
anymore just get over here get rid of
this [ __ ] and all this other stuff not
want he's on the phone yelling - dusty
he hears a that sound again and there's
somebody up on the roof now he grabbed
the flashlight he runs outside and he
shines the flashlight up on the roof and
he saw a figure yeah I talked to him
about that on the rail yeah I asked him
I said I said what was it you actually
saw on the roof and he kind of started
like dude I don't even want I don't even
want to talk about it I had the feeling
he couldn't describe it yeah and then it
upset him and it what probably was was
just kind of a scary amorphous shape
kind of any humanoid I think all he said
on the show was that it was a dark
figure yeah yeah so yeah he thought
running around the group and started
yelling at it and trying to hide it with
a flashlight yeah I'm not sure he
actually got a good look hot look at it
based on his yeah I mean in the
reenactment it was dark outside so I
don't know when he said he did see a
dark figure on the roof and then he saw
it in the beam of his flashlight now
evidently while he was yelling at this
thing on his roof dusty pulls up in the
car
and you know it's like you know please
don't yell at them they don't like it
and you know it's not helping anything
so at this point she says well we don't
know what else to do
you know the Dunham's were not a member
of any church so they said well maybe we
should do just like a cleansing
ourselves we'll do the Native American
stage thing we can do some Christian
prayers well you know as long as you
believe in it whatever it'll work she
says it'll take a couple days we'll get
everything set up and we'll come by and
we'll do a cleansing on your house and
hopefully it will it will work now while
Dusty's their best says you know can you
set up use one of your cameras and set
it up in the baby's room because I don't
think she's been sleeping and I don't
know why so as this is going on they
suddenly start hearing noises from the
baby's room and the baby suddenly starts
crying you know they say they run down
there now there's nobody in there but
the baby is just like seems really upset
and disturbed and stuff like that so the
denim's decide well let's put Emily in
our room just to be on the safe side but
we're going to set up a camera on the
crib to see if there's something keeping
her awake yeah this is where I start
getting mad yeah that's about right
people who've seen this episode and I
imagine most people listen and have seen
this episode what happens next just
makes me mad okay go ahead yeah so
basically that like a day or two goes by
dusty comes back they do the cleansing
and everything like that and everything
seems fine like after the cleansing Beth
said you know the house felt a little
bit better it wasn't so oppressive and
stuff like that Mae thought maybe if
things had been fixed meanwhile this is
a couple like after the cleansing dusty
is there and she's like oh I'll switch
out your videotape or whatever now she
takes the videotape of the you know that
was trained on the crib and she takes it
back to the office and she's watching it
now she claims that on the videotape
there is and they only show a
reenactment but she says that she heard
a voice saying the baby's name and then
saw like the there was a door like
behind the cravin it opened by itself
and then there was like a dark figure
like looming like over the crib and then
the baby started to cry that's what they
showed on the reenactment and it was
kind of like vague like what does
she saw in the paper but it apparently
alarmed her enough that she jumped right
in the car and drove back to the
Dunham's house to tell them to get the
[ __ ] out now while she was driving to
the house she gets a phone call from the
psychic in Pennsylvania who says I've
done the reading on the house like the
pictures that she got sent they need to
get the hell out of that house right now
because there's something like really
malevolent presence in there and it's
after the baby so dusty drives back to
the house and she basically runs in and
she says now I don't think I'm the
Reenactment I don't think she showed
them the tape she said you have to get
out because of what's on this my
understanding the tape was never shown
to anyone yeah which that that defies
credulity to me yeah dr. Hewitt I hit
the jackpot like that you could become a
very famous woman yeah a very wealthy
woman if you had that video the claim is
is that it was not shown to anyone
because they did not want to upset the
family he asked me I'm not buying it my
trust in the investigating well I would
want to see it yeah my trusting
investigative team was was shaken by
this all right if that tape exists it
needs to be seen yeah ninjutsu but I
mean apparently and and like I said I'm
Beth on the show and dusty was on the
show as well you know they didn't have
any animosity toward her they seemed
like should they said she was a very
nice person and she came in at that said
life and she's not not yet so so just
saying that but they did not help her of
that ecology at all it really does all
right but what I was leading up to is
that they immediately immediately
believed her evidently yeah when she
came in and said what is on this tape
that it's after baby we you have to move
out you have to get out right now
it can fry chime in you know T chimes
and in the comments I believe that I
actually kind of believed it by the time
that that tape that this claim came to
light I kind of think that they were
ready to get the hell out of there
anyway
maybe I don't think it was just that
well apparently because it seemed like
there was so much tension in the house
and you know it just seems like
everything like everything was going to
[ __ ] they were fighting all the time the
baby wasn't sleeping the baby was crabby
and it just seemed like a bad situation
all around
anything more so yeah that was pretty
much it they packed up their stuff they
got it now in every enactment they
should while they were packing their
stuff and running out of the house the
crib like flipped itself over right none
of them said that but like I said that's
that's the problem that a haunting has
is like they'll show stuff in the
reenactment that nobody said or at least
didn't say on camera so so they moved
don't hear my verdict they got the hell
out of the house and that was pretty
much the end of story they moved to
another town and apparently they got
divorced later but uh you won't hear my
verdict yeah what's your verdict just
based on the strength to add is eed and
adds character and the way he told me
the story and what was actually said and
I guess you could say the flavor of
talking to of talking with him you know
he's a credible guy never witnesses his
family you know saw some his
disturbances so I believe I believe the
family something scared them in that
house the problem I have is the
investigative team it was the way it was
investigated was very much of the of
that era
ya know what I know now I probably the
Senate guy like Steve marital to the
house like that which is a lot more
low-key you're not doing with a bunch of
different people from different
disciplines you're dealing with one
person who's trying to actually collect
evidence because if they collected in
the evidence they're not sharing it and
that doesn't that doesn't jive with me
yeah I mean if you've got good evidence
as a claim then it should be should have
been shared with the rest of the should
have been shared without any SPR well
and I only if you're going to do an
investigation on a place like that you
think that the team would want to like
live in the house yeah or at least set
up there for long periods of time
instead of just you know a few hours
here and there right and I don't really
don't I wouldn't really get involved
with the psychics too much it was just
with canvas basically yeah this is what
I would deal with cameras in a
controlled environment Danny what's
happening but uh you know that was the
way that was the way cases were
investigated in that time and a lot of
them are still investigated that way now
on the elevation yeah yeah no but that's
that's not the good way to do it in
which you know but I do believe that the
case happened again from the point of
view of the family I don't know what the
put the investigators you know
what they claim to have collected in
Seattle now yeah where's this videotape
you know yeah cuz I mean like apparently
it was so upsetting that where's the
readings off of all these EMF meters
yeah which Steve will tell you Steve
marrow tell you those EMF meters don't
mean all that much you have to use them
the right way yeah you can't just walk
around waving that thing around there's
electromagnetic fields everywhere in the
house yeah it really mean much well the
whole reason that they you would be
actual like real quote-unquote
parapsychology use them is because
they're trying to get a base baseline
reading so they can see where all the
appliances are causing mmm rated at all
so they know if something strange
happens that it's not available to
natural causes I think it was a
well-meaning investigation I just don't
think was effective by today's standards
yeah and like I said I guess it was in
the factory cuz I got the evidence are
you on they didn't collected eminent ax
to the family ended up moving to a
driving go bad anyway what you know
whether it was because the haunting was
really as bad as as the team made it
seem or because they were just sick of
it well what we went on if it was a us
if it was a hoax what was the motive I
would not know I don't think it was yeah
I don't think it was a hoax either
because there was no motive I'm just
saying that the only possible motive and
maybe ed was trying to skip out on his
lease but I find that unlikely yeah why
would they put themselves through all
that [ __ ] that's yeah that's no no no
well yeah and I mean in a lot of cases
you know I'm willing to concede like
some cases you know maybe was just
misidentification or some like that yeah
some cases are hoaxes but most of the
time why would you bother it just seems
like too much trouble bit I guess unless
you're making a [ __ ] ton of money which
which he wasn't I guess it was a bad
house yeah but I knew where it was I
wrote it out there this is a long time
later there's people living in it now
you know I mean and I just kind of
stopped outside of it and looked at it
and see if I could feel any feelings
from that I couldn't is this just like a
normal house yeah oh this is how I met
II dunno yeah I went up to AIDS Hardware
to go buy some fasteners I was building
something for a motorcycle and a guy
helping me find Ben he's Allen Allen
bolts you know I'm
I'm looking at this place guy sounds
really familiar and I look down his name
plate and if it says IDI with two DS
yeah I want man that they're dumb
because I had just seen ya haunting in
Florida case on the haunting maybe like
a few weeks before yeah
and that was when I got interested in
that case and it was if that was 2001
they need ten well now it was no because
I've been after that huh yeah well
because we haven't lived here
oh that's right we were living here at
the time yeah yeah yeah could be a
hardware is only right right about that
I remember three years ago done only
maybe three or four years ago cuz we've
only lived here for what five or six
years yeah so it couldn't have been that
long ago yeah he didn't know me from
Adam but he we instantly started talking
army and then I told him real quick I
said we uh you know I was you know there
was a bit you had written a book about
me called the math Mountain poltergeist
and I asked if I could talk to him
Facebook a yes so I got his hooked up
with him on Facebook called mom phone
talk to him few times I tried to get him
to come on and share with you the day
but he's still working construction so
that's wearing him out he was used
feeling sorry for himself so I'm getting
old man I'm getting old it works killing
me but the yeah he's still a good guy
yeah broke up with his wife got his own
now you know it's just it was so weird
to me that of all the people to run into
like you run into him visit yeah you get
ace hardware's I didn't like it a year
later I was all right and then like a
year later as I was on my bike full
armor at a red light
turn over London ed was in the car next
to me yeah I mean what's up at Ian's
exact you so here flip really close by
then I think it did at that time I don't
think he was in this area too much team
or I could asking but yeah so he was by
yeah he lives like a car that's just
that's very funny yeah yeah definitely I
mean I do think that there's something
and like I said other than seeing
apparitions nothing super super out
there no demons or nothing like what is
well not from the roof things banging
cabinets opening apparition weird noises
the typical things that are worked up
like feeling the repression are being
watched and stuff like that which is
pretty common typically pretty common
for haunting low level honking just
interesting because of the of the
apparitions that kind of
occurred right out of the gate and then
it almost seems like the poltergeist
stuff happened after that we're not kind
of unusual because usually it ramps up
there I wouldn't really call it
poltergeist there wasn't anything
removed just sounds well the cabinet
doors oh that's right and the shower
that yeah that's right so that is a
poltergeist type effect yeah but that
sometimes reported in haunting sure
where there's kind of a gap on overlap I
got great overlap yeah okay hope you
enjoyed that breakdown of another
episode of a haunting I like doing these
actually yeah maybe I can have it on
sometimes yeah yeah he can be a guest on
the show I may actually be pretty cool
he seems like really cool and as so as
always if you like the show please
subscribe to our youtube channel like us
on facebook follow us on twitter and all
that good stuff also go to WWE and there
are some t-shirts there that you can
have if you want
also another shout out to the project's
Entertainment Network and our mod Reza
Millia who is running our blog network
here check them check them out they have
like a bunch of other really cool shows
that I'm sure you will enjoy and also
give to their patreon because they have
like a bunch of cool swag that you can
have including a bunch of postcards of
our of our podcast that we signed yeah
so aggressed yeah we have we autographs
about the magnets is that why what song
you to close out with I'm actually you
know what because it's a Florida
haunting I said well I'm just going to
use that as an excuse to use the grim
grinning ghosts song from the Haunted
Mansion okay so be sure to tune in next
Tuesday bye
[Music]
written it in two ways not right way and
like the whole cake and roof of their
life in Vegas club as well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]